but let's start this morning with some
immediate live reaction to the events in
Russia from the government I'm joined
now by the chief secretary to the
treasury that's John Glenn good morning
Mr Glenn good morning now um the
government emergency response committee
Cobra met yesterday
um
what is the government's understanding
of the situation in Russia this morning
we were right Cobra was convened chaired
by the foreign secretary this is
fundamentally an internal matter for
Russia obviously observing it it is
obviously a very unstable situation in
Russia but it is fundamentally an
internal matter and we've obviously
urged alongside our allies which
conversations have been had over the
last 24 hours uh that obviously civilian
interests are considered and they seem
to have done that but this isn't a
matter that we would be intervening in
but obviously we observe and monitor the
situation on an ongoing basis very
carefully well look I know I know that
the Diplomatic language is it's an
internal matter not for us to comment on
and all the rest of it but doesn't this
alter the equation in Ukraine where we
have invested billions and where we have
an interest well we as a government have
been committed from the start on
supporting Ukraine in their battle
against what Putin has done and we will
continue to remain focused on that we
continue to train troops support with
military support and we're United with
our allies in leading in that effort
that will continue that is a separate
matter to what's happening in Russia
over the last couple of days uh did I
hear you say we've sent troops to the
Ukraine we've been training troops I
visited them in Salisbury Plain just
this week okay so uh this involves no
interruption or indeed no escalation of
our effort because there are some people
who would now say that actually
um this might mean an escalation by the
Russians or in their assault on Ukraine
the Wagner merceries are now we
understand being integrated with Russian
troops so might this be the moment for a
bit more support for Mr zielinski and
his team well we will work very closely
with Ukraine as the situations evolved
and as it has evolved over uh recent
months and that is our primary focus
supporting Ukraine deal with Putin in
whatever form that attack takes and it
has evolved over recent months so
nothing has changed with respect to the
British government's position in
supporting Ukraine I obviously recognize
these are concerning events uh of what's
happened in Russia but as I said we will
remain very close to our allies Cobra
has evaluated alongside our allies what
has been happening and urged concerns of
civilians to be taken into account but
this isn't something that we would
intervene in it's an internal matter for
Russia all right well let's um talk
about the things that are internal to us
and uh you're the economy your control
the economy let's let's start with that
inflation in this country is running
much higher than in uh comparable
countries we compare for example with
the Eurozone and the Americans the
Americans down there four percent
um but it's not actually just a level
but the fact that
the Americans uh inflation is down a bit
the Eurozone is down a bit ours is stuck
at 8.7 now we know the bank of England
has got its one Club interest rates
they've uh put on 50 50 basis points
this week let's talk about what the
government can do what give me one thing
that you in the treasury are doing to
tackle this inflation well as Chief
secretary to the treasury my
responsibility uh fundamentally and
primarily is to control public spending
and that is an incredibly challenging
job at this time because obviously we
had a three-year comprehensive spending
review uh two years back and obviously
these inflationary pressures bear down
across all our public expenditure on
Capital expending and on day-to-day
expenditure but keeping a grip on public
spending making tough decisions on
reprioritization uh putting an
efficiency Savings review Into the
preparation for the last fiscal event
the last budget and you will know
obviously that the chancellor asked me
to lead a productivity review which I'm
now undergoing and that will happen over
the next few months looking at how we
can control public spending a very
difficult time as we still deal with
many legacies from covid all very
sensible but explain to me how any of
that has any bearing on that 8.7 percent
figure in the next few months which is
when it's hurting well I can understand
and I really do understand because
obviously I have constituents who email
me or concerned about the implications
of higher interest rates for their
household budgets but there isn't a
single quick lever that I can give you a
Sign by I'm just asking you for one well
one contribution well I think there are
three elements to the government's
response the independent monetary policy
interest rates which you've described
controlling public expenditure and then
helping with those additional costs so
we've helped with those energy bills and
we extended that in the spring budget
but I I would just yeah coming down
anyway can I the big thing here is
mortgages isn't it can I can I just
point out that I think by putting one
screenshot on on your screen you failed
to show the fact that the interest rate
pressures across the across Europe and
across many of our allies Australia
Canada U.S interest rates have gone up
the fastest rate since the 1980s this is
a common experience now you're obviously
rightly asking me what's happening in
the UK and I'm telling you that but what
I am saying to you is there isn't one
single thing I can do sat in Whitehall
that's going to resolve this okay one
month okay fair enough I but I did make
the point that actually the problem for
us is that ours is stuck others are
going there Let's do let's interrogate
some of those things just let's start
with the bank of England by the way
where you do you don't have control over
what the bank of England does no but you
do have control over who is running the
bank of England and your transport
secretary colleague Grant shapes
um told my colleague Sophie Ridge uh
Mark Harper at beg your pardon told my
um my colleague Sophie Ridge earlier on
this week that uh
he thought that the bank would have been
too slow
well we remain in the treasury
completely aligned to the bank they as
you say have responsibility for interest
rate policy they've had that for over 25
years and if you look at it over those
25 years they've been uh pretty
effective in keeping it to the two
percent inflation Target these are
incredibly difficult times and they have
made their decision that the MPC
committee made that decision last week
and we worked closely with them in in
lockstep with them they are independent
of us so they make those judgments and
you wouldn't expect me to comment on
that yeah they're independent view but
you appoint the head so from what you
said Andrew Bailey's safe in his job for
time being well he had an eight-year
term I think he was appointed at the end
of 2019. I work very closely with Andrew
in a previous job when he was head of
the FCA and we we support him in taking
the decisions necessary so no p45
insight for Mr Bailey um can we just
deal with one other thing whether
they're loading Noises Off can we stop
talking about tax cuts now that's not
going to happen is it well you know that
we never talk about uh measures before
fiscal events
um obviously the Headroom that we had at
previous fiscal event in the spring is
now in in a different state in because
of the interest rate payments we have to
pay now basically we shut down the
economy we spent a lot of money when we
came out of covid we had a lot of debt
interest to pay that has gone up because
interest rates have gone up and that
makes our public finances very
challenging to significant once in a
hundred years and once in several
generation events of war in Europe the
government is here to deal with whatever
circumstances
are happening and we are taking the
right decisions at a difficult time as
the IMF indeed endorsed in that recent
assessment of the UK economy I'm taking
that as an answer that
um tax cuts are not on your agenda I've
got I think the prime minister's made
very clear the chances made very clear
that our priority is halving inflation
that's the dominant threat to the UK
economy and that's what we're most
focused on at this time all right let's
deal with something that is absolutely
in your control
um
one thing that wouldn't help inflation
is a big increase in energy builds and
Telegraph is reporting that uh the 170
pound a year green level levees that
were template temporarily removed are
going to come back onto bills next month
is that true were we making assessments
all the time of how we can deal with the
challenges of Supply across the economy
and the different input costs I can't
confirm those uh that this morning but
we are looking carefully at everything
that the chance they'll be meeting with
Regulators next week and we met with the
FCA and Bank lenders for example on
Friday to deal with the pressures that
households are facing with their
mortgages and we will continue to do
everything we can across all Departments
of government so I'm taking it no
decisions being taken but the re
restoration
of that Levy is on the table well in in
the sense that when governments are
facing really challenging times all
decisions are are looked at in terms of
what we can do to make the situation
better whilst continuing to recognize
that halving inflation has to remain our
priority that's the lens that the
government is consistently and unitedly
focusing on okay one way in which you
could make life easy for yourself is
um if
you passed if banks were to pass on
um the rate Rises
um to Savers in the way that the
mortgage uh increases uh are passed on
to mortgage holders Rachel Reeves uh has
written to the chancellor saying that um
there should be action from him and
Regulators to make sure that Savers
benefit from the change in interest
rates good idea Norm well I I recognize
the concern exists the chancellor
himself has recognized that that this is
something we're monitoring very
carefully we he's met with the FCA and
the banks on Friday the primary focus
was dealing with the implications of the
higher interest rates in that
conversation and several positive things
came out of that in terms of the
opportunity to go to interest only for
six months to have conversations with
your lender and not Prejudice your
credit rating as well as delaying
repossession from the first time you
miss a payment that was a constructive
set of conversations and we'll continue
to look at the the app if you like
between the interest on savings and the
headline rates all right well look let's
talk about something that's in your
personal uh purview and that is you
mentioned already public sector pay now
if you want to keep
um public expenditure down a big chunk
of that is pay the times is reporting
that the prime minister is going to
overrule the independent pay review
bodies and block the recommendations for
the next round of pay sector Award of
around six percent six and a half
percent
um is that right no what what happens is
we have the reports of the pay review
bodies most of those have come in and
then we look at those and make an
assessment now obviously in some of the
disputes we've had in recent months
they're near to resolution we've
obviously very pleased that several of
the NHS unions have agreed the agenda
for change deal five percent and then
four percent and some different changes
across working practices and we will
look at those pay review body reports
and that'll be the prime minister and
the chancellor working together with
input from me on what the the right way
of resolving yourself okay let's just
get this clear though you guys have been
saying for the best part of a year when
there were strikes wait for pay review
body we will support what the
independent pay review body said we have
to accept what the pay review bodies say
are you now telling me that actually
it's not quite that we are going to look
at what the pay review bodies say and we
may accept it now what we're saying is
that we haven't had all the pay review
body uh no but as a matter of principles
as a matter of principle pay review
bodies are a very significant part of
resolving the the pay uh issues but
obviously we've also got to take account
of the effect on inflation uh that would
be irresponsible not to do that so so we
haven't finished that process forgive me
forgive me if I bang on about this
because last time I was sitting here I
can't remember which of your colleagues
were saying this to me
pay review buddy got to go with pay
review and that was when actually the
pay review was recommending something uh
lower than what the unions wanted and it
was all fine then in principle to
support the pay review body what you're
telling me this morning is oh it's just
one factor we've got to think about
other things
is there other pre-review bodies
recommendations only sacrosanct when
they why benefit you guys I know what
I'm trying to tell you is that I can't
give you the conclusion of the pay
review body review process
I can't give you that yet because we
haven't finished that analysis but what
I'm saying to you is at the same time as
we're looking at that we're also aware
of the implications for inflation and
that is critical and the prime
minister's top priority has set out at
the start of the year and as he as he'll
be saying in interviews today okay I'm
sorry I don't need to be rude but it's
just that the last time I spoke to one
of your colleagues they weren't waiting
for the pay rude buddies to report they
simply said we'll accept what they did
what they what they're going to report
as you can see with some of these pay
review bodies and the implications and
the distribution between a non-con
payment and the weight where you do over
one year or two years these are factors
that are relevant it's not quite as
straightforward
um your colleague Jillian Keegan over at
education yeah says that big pay Rises
for teachers would be inflationary yeah
and I'm quoting her here
are ongoing strikes
um uh to quote language from earlier an
earlier era perhaps
um uh ongoing strikes a price worth
paying to keep pay and inflation down I
don't think anyone wants to see strikes
across any of our Public Services I
understand what leads to that situation
but what the government's got to do is
take responsible decisions on public
spending in the round pay is a
significant element of that and
obviously I'm very aware of the massive
contribution that teachers nurses and
public sector workers make and we've got
to get the right outcomes that are fair
to them but also aren't inflationary and
as you put up on that initial slide at
the start of our conversation this
morning you know inflation is going to
be tough to get down it's something that
we're focused on and we are united and
determined to do so John Glenn thank you
very much for your time